In order to solve this quadratic inequality we need to first factor. When we
factor we get that quantities x plus 2 and x minus 1 are less than or equal to
0. This gives us our critical points of x equal negative 2 and x equals 1. So if
you look over here at our number line, we have our number line with the critical
points on it, and we will begin to look at which intervals are true or false. So
now you can see we have 3 intervals. We have an interval from negative infinity
to negative 2, from negative 2 to 1, and from 1 to infinity. So if we pick a
point in each interval and check to see if it's true, we'll find out where out
solution set lies. So, let's check in our first interval, negative infinity to
negative 2. Let's select the point negative 3. So we select negative 3 in
interval negative infinity to negative 2. You can see we obtain the solution of
4, 4 is not in the interval negative infinity to negative 2. So we selected
three points, let's look at x equals -3 first, when we substitute that in, we
get 4. Is less than or equal to 0 which is not a true statement. The second
point we select is 0 we get negative 2 is less than or equal to 0 we can see
that, that is a true statement. And the last point we selected 2 when we
substitute that in we get 4 is less than or equal to 0 which is also not a true
statement. So our solution lies between negative 2 and 1, including both of
those points. Our solution is negative 2 is less than or equal to x, which is
less than or equal to 1.